[Music]
Brandon it's so great to be here with
you today it's a pleasure I'm having so
much fun right now me too honestly so
let's start off by talking to me about
exactly what meow does meow is a high
interest banking platform so it's like
look if you go to Costco you feel like
you're getting a good price right the
reason that happens is because Costco
basically went to bat for you with their
suppliers they beat them down on price
they got you a good price regardless of
how rich you are what if someone applied
that to business checking accounts so
that's what we're doing we beat down
Banks our banking Partners on price and
what we do is anyone who onboards to
meow to get a business checking account
they can feel like they're getting a
really good interest rate through the
platform and how exactly are you doing
that so there's only been a few
companies that have ever successfully
attracted business banking deposits as a
fintech uh facing the startup market and
so we had a lot of social proof with us
when we went to these banking Partners
so we said look guys if you guys give us
a really good rate we'll attract more
customers to use your platform and they
said okay fine let's see what you you
can do and thankfully we crossed over a
billion in assets on the platform uh
through that so that's that's why we had
leverage here very cool now take me back
to the beginning I want to hear all
about your founding story yeah so my
co-founder and I we wanted to start a
company our whole lives uh thankfully Co
came around and it was a little bit
easier to raise funding we didn't know
any VCS he quit his job at Facebook he
just moved into an apartment with me we
just started coding non-stop yeah
thankfully we got our first uh check an
investor who believed in US and one
thing led to another we built a great
team and we built a good company since
then thankfully very cool what was it
like you know switching into
entrepreneurship and and taking on that
challenge for the first time it was
terrifying yeah I mean quitting our jobs
and not having any kind of fall back any
income any plan really was was kind of
scary um it was like the abyss it's like
staring into the darkness and not
knowing what's there and we just kind of
coated our way out of it and thankfully
we could see a light at the end of the
tunnel which was just our first customer
and our first Angel check was there a
moment for you where you you know
thought like hey I think that this risk
is actually going to pay off you never
you have this kind of blind confidence
in yourself and your team but that kind
of Abyss never quite goes away you know
Elon Musk talks about how a startup is
staring into the abyss and chewing glass
and then eventually it's just chewing
glass uh so that's the best we can hope
for on any given day is just chewing
glass daily it's a good way to put very
visual exactly um what's been the most
challenging part about running
Meo challenging part is we're trying to
do everything with the leanest team
possible so when we cross a billion in
assets on the platform meow Technologies
Inc we were 12
people that leads to problems but it
leads to Opportunities I mean being so
lean every dollar we save we can
feasibly pass back to our customers but
that means we're constantly underwater
so we have to figure out how to further
automate make this like the most
efficient platform possible that's
that's really the challenge for us
speaking of automation how are you are
you thinking about Ai and and how that's
going to play a role in your business if
at all yeah you know AI is there's a lot
of hand waving about AI but one thing it
certainly does is it Roots out
inefficiencies and that can lead to cost
savings you know maybe an entire
department can be replaced by software
and if you can do that in financial
services then you can give small
businesses the opportunity to earn
meaningful yields that maybe it wouldn't
have been profitable to onboard them
without that kind of innovation so we're
definitely looking at it from that
perspective have you started using it at
all or is that kind of a future thing
for you we're getting pitched on it
daily as you can imagine like the
money's flying for AI um but yeah we're
we're kind of like in the medium stages
with a couple firms right now which is
pretty exciting Co So speaking of of
getting pitched and money flying I
definitely want to hear about your
fundraising Journey walk me through that
and and where you're at today yeah so
we've raised 30 million to date about
this is our first company and that's
kind of a high number for first- Time
founder with my co-founder Bryce so the
hardest part was getting the first check
because when you don't know any VCS
every VC is basically looking for social
proof like who else has invested in you
you don't have a good answer for that
when you're starting out so you have to
find that one VC who believes in you
before anyone else does and that's super
rare that was a guy named Charlie sers
for us and one thing led to another when
people saw Charlie invested then it's
like okay maybe I can invest too and
then kept going and going and thankfully
we raised raised some money and we can
do some big things with it I think what
was your pitch or what do you think got
Charlie to to actually say like all
right I'll give these guys a chance he
was a history nerd like me so I was just
pitching on like the history of money
and things like things you would never
put in a in a pitch right but thankfully
he understood what I was trying to
communicate behind the scenes like
there's a real business here to be done
so if I didn't get a smart person like
him on the call like it would have gone
the way of every other VC I talked to
before that definitely yeah and what has
fundraising afforded you what have you
been able to do because of it yeah it
allows us to make five six seven year
bets so we have like 10 plus years of
Runway right like we're very
conservative with our money and what
Jeff Bezos talks about is when your
company makes bets that are in the four
five six year range for an Roi you're
not really competing with anyone
everyone's kind of thinking quarter to
quarter year to year but if I can make a
long-term bet that pays off in six years
think about the magic we can create as a
business the value we can create to
maybe underserve communities underserve
businesses that's that's what I'm
getting excited about so that's great
talk to me about your customers who are
they how many do you have and if you're
able to name any would love to hear them
yeah so we've traditionally served the
startup market like C to series D um our
backers never thought that we'd be able
to get to the traction that we have
thankfully but we've gotten there and
now I really believe in this vision of
keeping our costs so low that we can
serve the smallest businesses that would
not get attractive rates elsewhere
because their deposit sizes aren't
enough so we're ex we're going down
Market basically to small businesses uh
you know getting profitable on them too
and that's going to open up the door to
I hope every business in America
basically use using the platform can you
talk to me a bit about your competition
who are they and what sets you apart
from them it's a good question so
something that resonated with us my
co-founder told me look we should never
focus on the competition Jeff bezo says
if you obsess over the customer uh you
don't even need to think about your uh
competitors at point so we do you know
there are major banks that are competing
with us there are major fintechs that
are competing with us like ourselves
that have you know 14 billion valuations
hundred billion doll valuations
thousands of people and we're sitting
here at 15 uh going head-to-head with
them but we just focus on the customers
they kind of guide us to the right path
anyway uh so we don't we don't we're try
not to think about competitors that much
I makes sense and you said you focused a
lot on on startups how was it earlier
this year where the whole Silicon Valley
Bank collaps what did that mean for you
and your business seriously yeah when
svb collapsed we saw more than half a
billion in inflows to our platform yes
that was crazy we were on like two phone
calls at once for most of the day it was
a scary situation for a lot of people
and I remember I saw a VC a prominent VC
make a uh LinkedIn post or something
that said this is so ridiculous people
are concerned about Silicon Valley Bank
and they're M moving to a fintech called
meow and uh yeah we're not a bank
obviously we're fintech but that that
was kind of what put us on the map is we
were there we helped a lot of customers
get bank accounts through our banking
Partners at that point were how did you
pitch these startups that had just kind
of lost everything did you reach out to
them did they find you yeah so it was in
the panic mode that a lot of them
reached out to us I mean that we're
never going to see an event like that
for our company's perspective where it's
just inbounds inbounds inbounds
constantly I mean we were not sleeping
honestly it was like 3 hours of sleep
that night I had a terrible cold it was
a terrible terrible time to get a cold
yeah of course um but we it was just
people were looking for lifeboats at
that time they were scared about losing
their money and that's a terrifying
situation I don't want any anyone to
ever feel like that again uh but yeah
that was definitely a moment where meow
was no longer just a funny name but it
was a meaningful company for a lot of
people well that's a perfect Segway tell
me about how you came up with the name
you know our the investors who passed on
us they said we would never see ,000
doar come to meow we'd never see a h
100,000 with the name meow and we're
over a billion on the platform I still
get questions about the name like it's a
happy high ceiling there's dopamine in
the name yeah when you say it just makes
you happy and if I was going for like a
single or a double I would have named it
something more boring right but Bryce
and I wanted to be a household name with
unlimited potential and why not just
pick the happiest highest cealing name
you could think of do you love cats is
that why I I'm a dog person that's a
crazy thing yeah
I I like cats yeah they're fine I like
the word meow though I respect them it
is it's a great word yeah I'm happy when
I say it so what's it been like to be a
young entrepreneur especially in a
finance industry where it's a very old
industry have you had any impostor
syndrome or how does it feel yeah it's a
very good question so when you go to we
partner with banks right so we're not a
bank ourselves and a lot of the banks
are run by let's say traditional folks
who are a little bit skeptical about
techn technology and newcomers Etc so
that's kind of doubly the case when your
name is meow technology Inc but we've
kind of beaten that down by showing that
we can bring value to customers and
attracting deposits for these Banks and
the partners get get it over some a
period of time so I think everyone's
kind of willing to you know adopt to the
new age adapt rather and that's been
that's been really positive for us very
cool what would it take for you to sell
your company and is that your goal it's
not my goal to sell the company what
excites us at meow is impact so we want
to become like the single Gateway for
businesses that are trying to access
High interest bank accounts through our
banking Partners anywhere in the globe
and what gets us really excited is not
hiring a thousand people hiring 2,000
people like high valuations it's getting
our costs so low that we can onboard
companies by the skin of our teeth
profitable unit economics on them and
serve them whereas another bank maybe
wouldn't have maybe maybe they wouldn't
have given them that high of of an
interest rate because it wouldn't be
profitable
we want to be maniacally obsessed about
our costs and get access to everyone um
this platform excellent do you have any
um plans of expanding globally or
where's your reach right now yeah so we
just expanded into the UK actually great
yeah we're we're working with a lot of
the high net worth uh companies there uh
for some of our offerings and again we
start kind of up Market in the startup
world like C through series D we kind of
use those revenues uh to then go down
market and serve these more underserved
businesses that's what really excites
yeah very cool is there one business
rule that you always operate by no
matter what I'd say there's two okay one
is don't take existential risks if you
stay in the game you win in the game if
you think about all the companies that
that failed like publicly in the past
three four years they shot themselves in
the foot by being greedy not being
greedy is a superpower if you just stay
in the game you don't take existential
risks good things happen and the other
rulle is just obsess over your customer
do right by them Jeff Bezos again says
there's never any Miss alignment between
shareholder value and customer
satisfaction in the long run so if you
do right by your customers you can only
become a trillion dollar company if they
give you their explicit permission they
will make you the trillion dollar
company if you do right by them it's up
to them so those are the two things that
we live by and it's it's thankfully
worked to us talk to me about a hard
situation you may have faced either with
a customer or an employee and how you
overcame that and went through
it I had a lot of pressure to spend the
money that we raised as you can imagine
so we we haven't touched a penny of our
22 million series a over a year and a
half ago which is really unusual yeah
people will pressure you to you got to
spend to grow you how are you gonna
spend how are you going to grow if
you're not going to spend we got that
from a lot of uh potential investors a
lot of our investors understood we
wanted to be super conservative because
we kind of saw the market we saw the
where the ball was going we saw a bare
Market coming around the corner like
we're in right now um but thankfully
like we have a good investing base they
they understand us they trust us we've
delivered for them so uh that's been the
biggest pressure we we face today is
there any advice you would give your
younger self the day before you started
your company that you wish you knew
now that's a good
question
the I would say there's a difference
between working hard and working smart I
had a tendency to want to scrub like
read every P every word of every
textbook transcribe it onto a notebook
to prove that I understand it right just
like ridiculous things like that I felt
like the longer hours I worked on
something the more it demonstrated like
my knowledge on it there's ways to work
be more efficient with your time without
kind of hurting yourself over it uh so
I'd say time management is a big one
something you have to learn as a pounder
ultimately so what's next for you tell
me about any exciting updates or or news
and what are you what are you looking
forward to from Meow in 2024 it's such a
simple like business model like you know
there's an email of me that it's
floating around where I told one of our
investors when we had like 5 million in
assets on the platform that I'm not
going to be happy until we had a billion
and we cross a billion and now I I'm
telling people I'm not going to be happy
until we have 10 and then 100 what
excites me is not getting whales on the
platform it's getting smaller and
smaller businesses that can actually
move the needle for them financially
that that are potentially underserved I
want to serve every small business in
the world uh in America starting with
America and I just want to keep growing
this thing just make meow I want people
to meow all over the world I want to
hear that word everywhere it just lights
me up when I say it I I like it too and
like how do you look at marketing then
for your company are you one of the
subway ad peoples or how do you how do
you go about that we don't believe in
Billboards is the thing like we we think
every penny we spend on like marketing
and ads like could be a penny that goes
in the customer's pocket right so
thankfully we got a lot of Word of Mouth
it's a name you don't forget so that
that really helps the t-shirts really
soft and they say meow on them so people
wear them they actually like do
marketing for us when we just spend like
10 bucks on a t-shirt interesting okay
and what would you like your legacy to
be
honestly if we at the company we just
want to make an impact we just want more
people to be we just get excited when
people use the product right yeah and
you know there's 30 million what small
businesses in America having people use
meow uh to access bank accounts through
our platform I mean that just that would
just light me up if every business was
using us I mean that's just that's a
great legacy to have absolutely well
thank you so much Brandon I appreciate
you being here with me thank you had a
blasted
yeah
[Music]